let's get a round of applause for Jackie
over being such a good spot while an out
star Miss Jackie O has died she was 32
years old VH1's parent company bet Media
Group confirmed her death on Thursday in
a tribute saying quote Jackie O was a
loving friend and beloved colleague of
the show's cast for Five Seasons and her
impact quote will be forever treasured
and missed I'm a bit of a rebel when it
comes to this because I'm a vet so I
don't really follow the rules TMZ
reports that the TV personality real
name Jacqueline Smith died in Miami no
other details about her cause of death
have been released
was survived by her partner DC Young Fly
daughters Nova Nala and Son Prince
birthday is
what's your favorite thing about him
[Music]
you love his fat cheeks yes
teach them everything I know
[Music]
foreign